Mình đã phát bây giờ, người phát ngôn định gremlin Dimitri Pest Coctin bố,
ngàn coi các lệ trường phát đường phương của Linh Mi Chau AU là bất hợp pháp,
và khám định mắt sửa phát đối mẹ.
Tế bố được đưa ra sau khi AU thông qua gó trường phát của người tháng,
nhưng vòng ngàn lên qua để chúng đủ ruo quay nâh.
Gó này bao gồm việc giám chân, ra rau xuất khẩu của ngàn xuống con,
đủ mi vậy, phải sau đủ lầm mi của thông.
Cùng các biển pháp hạn chế hoàn đậu của đường ông dòng chế phông bác
và kìm xuất tạo cho dầu, nhưng hằng cùng giống mật hạn xuất khẩu khác.
Ông Pest Coct, cho biết,
nha đã dần mi nhiễm với các biển pháp chân phát và sẹp tình ký nội dùng mới,
để đưa ra bể phát đường phó.
Ông kìm bao dần, các lệ trường phát của AU, là con ra hoai lửa,
và có thể gây hải nụ trở lại cho chính trâu áo.